Up to this point our requests
have been working fine, but
there's potentially
a big security problem.
If you've been paying attention,
our requests for
this app are being sent using HTTP.
We can see this if we go
to the app constants file.
We notice that our API scheme is HTTP.
And this scheme is what's being used,
here we go,
in the tndbURLFromParameters that's
using our ApiScheme, which is HTTP.
Now, while we've defined
the proper settings
in the info.plist file to allow for
this, there's still a big security risk.
Especially if we're making
requests that send usernames and
passwords as parameters of URL,
like we did when we logged into the API.
Let me show you what I'm talking about.
Let's go back to
the LoginViewController and
let's find that loginWithToken method,
here we go.
Let's add a print statement
that shows the URL for
the login request that we're making and
our loginWithToken method.
When I click the login button,
okay here's our URL, so
I've clicked the login button and
we can see that the URL's being
printed where the username and
password are sent as plain text.
So if somebody was watching the network
traffic going from my phone to a server,
or even from my simulator to a server,
they could see these values and
this is obviously very bad.
Let me show you how this might look for
somebody who's snooping
on network traffic.
I'm going to do this using
an application called Charles.
You don't need to install Charles
yourself, I'm just going to use it for
this example.
In Charles we can see all the web
traffic that's incoming and
outgoing on this particular machine.
So I want to see the requests that are
being sent to the movie database, and
as you can see,
we've made a request recently.
If I select this request and
then I go look at the summary,
I can actually see what the traffic
looks like as it's leaving my machine.
So I can take a closer look, and
here's our validate_with_login method,
I can actually see my username here, and
then here's my password in plain
daylight for everyone to see.
So we definitely need to fix this,
but thankfully,
it can be done really quickly
since the movie database provides
us a way to send requests
like these securely.
If we go back to the documentation
we can take a look at this HTTPS/SSL
section and, as we can see, it simply
tells us instead of making an HTTP
call ,we just need to make
an HTTPS call, and then we're set.
What this is effectively going to
do is by making the HTTPS calls,
it's going to encrypt all the data
that's being sent from our apps so
that nobody can snoop on us.
If you want to hear more about HTTPS,
now I put a link in the instructor notes
to our web development
discussions on the topic.
Okay, so to fix the problem we
just need to make one small change
in the constants.swf file.
Let's change our scheme
from HTTP to HTTPS.
Now we'll build this project.
Let's go and log in.
Now I'll go ahead and switch back over
to Charles and you'll see that we have
the HTTP request that we previously
did and then these HTTPS requests.
And as you can see, since we're using
https, we don't really know anything
in terms of snooping about
what's happening in our request,
whereas we can still see things that
are being passed with this request.
The best part about all of this is
we're pretty much getting it all for
free because the movie
database supports HTTPS.
So, when in doubt, just use HTTPS.